how many bodies does it take for a girl
to become a [__]
I don't think is the body kind I think
it's the frequency the for okay how
frequent so any multiple guys in a year
how many how many till [__] and how
long is she a [__] for can she ever
yeah 100 okay so in a year how many
bodies till she is officially [__] I
just think we should nail it down
I think if you have sex with more than
one guy a week that's different
you're a [__] I thought you were going
to say a year
I was waiting for a year a week so no
more than no more than
I'd say you should no more than really
ten no more than 10 in a year yeah okay
okay so if she has more if she has 11 in
a year [__] yeah I draw the line at 11.
horror okay what about what about the
next year she has zero was she still a
[__] she's she's rejuvenated
she's a born-again [__] definitely okay
what about what about how many in a year
uh I feel like it's hard to put a number
in it but I don't know yeah like 10 like
10 in a year yeah like I don't know
and then a double double digit it's like
yeah that's a bit crazy okay and then
can she on become a horse shoe yeah you
can like if you're if you stop being
sexually active and like completely and
you don't sleep with anyone then yeah
not really a [__] anymore yeah born
again all right what about you what
about how many in a year I say more than
three personally more than three in a
year yeah all right no you can't undo
being a [__] definitely I mean you
can't or you can't you can't yeah energy
yeah you can undo it passes to pass yeah
not to men unfortunately yeah you're a
[__] forever yeah and if you ask the
guys I'm telling you ask a guy the same
question
they'd be like 10. I thought they meant
that for a lifetime all right that's
what I thought when they said 10 I'm
thinking that's one a month with two
months to recover
that's I I look so and two I I think as
she has more than two but if you can be
a
born again [__] I want to be a virgin
[Laughter]
do you know what I mean I don't see how
it works
okay so I have I have some stats for you
guys some fun fun stuff okay here it is
all right according to a 2017 survey
conducted by the Center for Disease
Control and prevention the average
number of sexual partners in American
adults reported having in their lifetime
or in the UK but usually the numbers are
similar how how many average Partners do
you think the average woman has in her
lifetime guess on average yeah according
to the CDC
7 7 this is nothing to do with me guys
it's not my numbers but I think
50 50. I want to say five on average in
a lifetime yeah you're the Accord
according to to what the women say which
let's be honest let's
4.2 wow that's good that's good that's a
0.2 of a person well I think it's the
average Sophie you know in a lifetime
4.2 yes is that the new gen or the
object why is it worse for the 2017
2017. yeah no I don't think they should
them stats are not good they should come
ask people today because I think black
cultures change people are so much more
Freer with sexual partners and stuff
what what's changed what do you think
like I think that women are a lot more
free-minded with having sex with random
guys and multiple guys like it's okay
for them to sleep with more people where
obviously back in the day like 2017
sleeping with one one man was enough so
yeah I think those stats they don't they
don't count anymore or would you mean
multiple guys you said random and
multiple yeah like more than one guy
like at the same time someone I don't
know because when you said random you
can have loads of random when she said
multiple
these people just literally linking
people to have sex so you think you know
it must be about 15 is that average now
I said 50 babe 50. yeah like from what I
see from the culture and how people move
in I really do think that that's more of
a realistic number yeah so let's let's
do some math here okay so the average
the average age of first marriage in the
UK is 31. okay how long do you think
someone would date before they get
married like two years would you guess
yeah two to four years two to four years
so let's say she meets so 30 29 28 12
I'd say at 27 off the market with the
same guy
how many bodies did she get up to 27
would you say guess
average girl in the UK living in London
let's say London because London's going
to be different than like the other side
of England to average hour I'd say maybe
12. 12. but before didn't you say the
average number was 30. now I'm talking
based on today's statistics of a 27 year
old in London I feel like it's down to
12. I feel like by 27 she could have on
average I'm trying to even it out like
12 12. an average 20 to 27 I would say
like five six five six yeah Thirty
Thirty Thirty Auntie what do you think
[Laughter]
when she comes out of high school she
would have had 20 by the time she does
this but she's been his colleagues he's
not surprised and uni students it's like
an old yet there isn't it
yeah so why are we so hesitant to call
okay so
I don't have him in front of me so I'm
gonna be butchering this but if you're a
virgin on your wedding night and this to
be fair the stat is from a more Catholic
organization so you can take it with a
grain of salt but if you're a virgin on
your wedding night what do you think
your chance of a happy marriage is
um
I think a lot less than if he was to
have sex prior to marriage a lot a lot
you're less likely to be happy if you're
a virgin yeah okay why do you think that
because a lot of other a relationship is
sexual compatibility now I speaking on
myself I've been in situations where
you've not you've prolonged sex with
someone had sex with them and now
everything's just not good anymore no I
don't want to see you anymore because
there's no compatibility you have to you
have to know and understand a person
sexually before you can commit to them
for the rest of your life how did how
did you know how would you know they're
bad if you've never been with anyone
else because you know you know what
feels good enough and what doesn't feel
good and when you were a virgin did you
you did you feel like the person you
were like the first person you had sex
with was bad
no looking back on it now he did all
right to be fair yeah okay okay so what
about you versus virgin well you didn't
say a percentage what percentage
um what percent of that you wouldn't be
happy no would be like what percent have
happy marriages of virgins on their
wedding night
say about 25 25 okay I don't know for me
I just feel like you can't base your
happiness and marriage just based on sex
though no so they take they take you
know how many partners did you have
before marriage they fill out the survey
and then they say are you happily
married after 10 years so it's like what
percent of a hundred women are happy
after 10 years that are virgins on their
wedding night
yeah like again I just don't do you
agree do you do you think virginity has
any impact on the happiness of a
marriage no I don't you don't so it
doesn't matter if you've had a lot or a
little yeah could have what about a
hundred Partners okay 100 Partners
that's yeah okay that could definitely
affect your happiness emerged but
if you're a virgin I don't see how it
would necessarily affect your happiness
because you don't necessarily know how
it feels okay what do you think I think
like more like 80 percent uh because
it's sacred and I think that the man the
husband would cherish his wife a lot
more
um and they grow together they learn
together and usually if you're married
as a virgin you're young
do I mean so if they're not going to be
happy in the relationships not because
of the sex it's the emotional and mental
thing but yeah I think they'll be a lot
more happier I'll get married as a
virgin okay Auntie I think you'll be
high as well because you've got nothing
to compare it with and you know you
can't say he's rubbish because you don't
know how rubbish he is you just think
that's it so again this is from a more
Catholic organization so you can take it
with a grain of salt but 80 chance of a
happy marriage if you're a virgin on
your wedding day
I got you know there's free drinks
um so where
when do you think it changes so what
number of Partners do you think a girl
goes from typically being happy to being
unhappy
unhappy in what sense
um so again they say how many partners
did you have before marriage she says
two three four five ten twenty where do
you where do you see the number changing
um a lot basically I actually saw
something and it said that if you've
slept with more than 25 people by the
time you get married you have a higher
chance of divorce I don't know how
factual that is but um
okay so you think 25 roughly okay what
do you think
I'm trying to think
um
I'll see you in like 10 10 okay
yeah I'll say like 30 I think obviously
it affects the man and his ego and
which is not a bad thing do you know
what I'm saying he emotionally treat her
a certain way and always have this like
hangover so yeah maybe 38 38 what do you
think I can't remember a question how
many how many partners until it affects
a girl's mouth oh okay that's why I
wouldn't say that
sorry I was confused I'm just double
checking the stuff so I was kind of
happy before marriage can I just answer
that can I say anything above two a
piece
Third Time Lucky after two just get
married
yeah so
um after two it significantly goes down
it's like like 80 guys please don't
butcher me in the chat I know I know
it's like it goes down to roughly 50 but
after five Partners you have a 20 chance
of being in a happy marriage
so you go from an 80 chance to a 20 25
chance
a crazy statistics just off the five
yeah because what are the odds that
that's you know the best you can do
right like that the guy the fifth one is
the one you're happy with like what was
wrong with the first second third and
fourth so maybe you're just never happy
I have no chance of marriage I just want
to please